this sequence is called the kill floor
and in the graphic novel it's this
incredible uh illustrated sequence and i
remember thinking how amazing it was but
also having
a bit of fear of how the hell am i going
to bring this to life
in this sequence our characters the old
guard
our group of mercenaries and they
believe that they are here to rescue a
group of kidnapped girls in in south
sudan
but in fact they've been set up and
they're lured here
to get visual proof of their gift of
immortality
as well as to collect their blood bone
dna
so this is the first action sequence of
the film and we knew that it needed
to set the tone of the vision of the
film which was
a completely grounded reality despite
this fantastical conceit of
immortality it was important um given
that this was the first
scene where you were truly seeing the
old guard and their alter ego
to literally land the audience in
exactly who these people were as
warriors
it was important for me to find those
angles that really showed both the
individual skill set
of each of the characters as well as how
they worked in tandem
as the old guard is coming down the
stairs the only thing illuminating their
the room is the flashlights on the end
of their weapons
and then we had the lights at the end of
the room that pop on and that created a
beautiful silhouette of our team
which was a theme throughout the graphic
novel um
silhouettes of the team and we wanted to
honor that
we wanted to be able to shoot 360
degrees during the fighting so the room
is lit with just two lights they're like
the lights that merrick
installed so when the old guard he
surprises them and two bright lights
beam in their faces
and they're riddled with bullets so that
then he can
have a clear view of them regenerating
and then we also that shot it's one of
my favorites
as andy falls the flashlight falls and
lands right on her face
really illuminating her face so we see
her eye pop open and realize they've
come back to life
the regeneration is a big part of the
story and it's the first time the
audience get introduced to it in this
scene
we wanted it to feel organic as possible
and definitely stay away from the
magical
um tammy sent us a time-lapse clip of
like rotten-free
which gave us a good starting point for
you know where we could go with the
regeneration
i researched medical websites and it was
clear from looking at these that
there's a really high level of detail
and sort of intricate layers um
into this and but also we had to kind of
sell this idea over a few seconds
and not have it look comical and then
along with that we also added in
you know various like blood hits um
bullet casings
you know to sort of build up this whole
scene of carnage you know even so we get
to the end
um and we added in extra bodies weapons
casings
you know just to help sort of bring this
whole scene together we needed to be
realistic about the fact that these four
can come in
and go against the group of 18
mercenaries
our characters have archaic weaponry
because they've been alive for thousands
of years and that's how they fight
whereas the mercenaries have modern
weaponry for the fighting gene and i
felt like being really in there hand
held gave the audience a more
immersive feel instead of viewing it
from the outside when they're fighting
were in their right with them with the
cameras it was important
to see you know the precision and
efficiency at which they work both
individually and together because these
are people who've been together for
hundreds of thousands of years
and the fighting needed to reflect that
and especially being able to juxtapose
both keeping it wide enough where you
could really see the physicality of
their movement but at the same time
really dwell in the proximity in which
as
frankly ancient warriors they would
fight hand to hand
everyone still with me yeah
joe very pissed off
so where are the girls this is a violent
film i knew
i wanted to be unapologetic about the
violence but never wanted it to feel
like a celebration of violence we just
wanted to keep it real and grounded and
that
was about how much carnage we were going
to show and how we were going to show it
more like a war film
as opposed to a horror film we've been
set up
it also needed to set our visual style
which is something that tammy and i
called pretty gritty
and that was really trying to find the
beauty in the darkness of this world
that our old guard existed in it was
such a great opportunity and early on
to really come together bring our crafts
together
um to realize a vision and it was
beautiful to see what each of us
was able to bring to this to bring this
amazing sequence to life